c'est affreux imaginez que quelqu'un qui
rentre chez vous il plus qui commande
une pizza et la pizza il a le bon
comment de la pizza on considère pas un
peu plus fort dans le cder on considère
que c'est chez lui non enfin résidence
je te jure que c'est sartre idée voici
ce que je te dis ça parce que c'est un
problème c'est que quelqu'un qui rentre
chez toi il commet une pizza il a donc
une preuve comme quoi il habite chez toi
moi franchement j'ai vu plein de
reportages ce que vivent ces gens là
c'est et en plus faire et en plus non
seulement ils dissimulent en plus ils
massacrent l'endroit où ils sont aux as
qui casse tout l'iped tout c'est sale
c'est dégueulasse donc moi si ça
m'arrivait je vous dis franchement je
vais pas attendre ni une heure et deux
heures je vais les [ __ ] dehors moi
même vraiment je devrais havrais ah oui
quand on va élever à vraiment alors
c'est monsieur maurice signolet
d'ailleurs inquiète avec nous l'ancien
commissariat il va vous dire ce que vous
risquez aussi dans un instant gilbert
laissez jamais il faut faire confiance à
la justice
[Musique]
et nous qui nous fait ch il même il faut
surtout pas le faire il faut appeler les
forces de l'ordre qui viendront il faut
faire des conseillers après se faire
justice soi même ça veut dire quoi alors
et un jour si on est agressé dans la rue
on rend le coup chacun en prison c'est
très risqué il ya plus de limites il ya
plus de lois plus de cannelle de limites
non non mais si jamais se faire justice
et tu sais pas ça coûte de faire un
constat d'huissier sait combien ça coûte
de faire bien justement tu n'as rien
quand tu n'as pas d'argent tu peux très
bien me annoncés bien gelly porte et
mature et de migrer des constats
d'huissier faut qu'ils viennent il faut
se loger en attendant quelque part n'est
pas remboursé très bien que gad et 1000
euros par mois tu veux qu'on faisait la
justice venu me virer les gens
ya moi c'est drôle j'ai un tout petit
studio de 15 mètres carrés dans le 1er
arrondissement et il ya ces requêtes est
cassé et la police est venue bon ils ont
rien trouvé de danse et livide et m'ont
dit tout de suite tout de suite tout de
suite changé de serrure si quelqu'un
rentre dans la nuit ça c'est fini vous
ne pouvez plus sortir il est chez lui
j'ai halluciné voilà c'est halluciné
donc je veux dire quelqu'un dans la nuit
c'est pas même pris au sérieux c'est
dans la nuit là c'est pas le mépris que
la journée c'est hallucinant donc je
suis désolé encore une fois ça peut
s'entendre quand on a plain appartement
quand on a de l'argent et tout ça mais
des gens qui mettent tout crédit dans
une maison et faire des bisous
s'il gagne très bien sa vie dans le
monde mais c'est à dire mais si
ça c'est pas vrai nom sur le film gilles
et si les lois été bien faites on les
respecte ray mais mais là vous respectez
pas les lois
mais c'est une aberration du travail
touch jury pour un truc après une année
en plus hypes insultes il te menace
quand tu veux récupérer ton du messin
croyable avant d'être en train de parler
des règles de miss france qui ont évolué
mais faisons évoluer les règles de la
france et nos chers politiques qu'on a
réélu on pourrait pas leur dire qu'ils
jettent un petit coup d'oeil sur tout
c'est loin qui sont vraiment mais on
sait l'aveyron d'une vie pour le
fruit d'une vie entière de témoignages
tu veux dire à l'autre droite
oui non mais m'a énervé c'est bien de
suivre la loi mais la loi n'a aucun sens
la loi protège beaucoup trop les
squatteurs et ce qui est insupportable
dans leurs démarches la démarche de
certains squatteurs c'est qu'ils pensent
que tous les propriétaires sont des gens
extrêmement fortunés voilà ils s'en
foutent complètement de ne pas pouvoir
vivre chez eux qui de toute façon 15
logements et malheureusement ce n'est
pas la réalité les gens qui se font
voler leur domicile ils sont obligés de
se rendre chez eux tous les jours pour
négocier que les squatteurs parfois y en
a qui vivent dans des tentes devant les
maisons face et le monde à l'envers donc
il faut que la loi change est évidemment
que dans ces cas là il faut se faire
justice soi même on peut attendre
pendant des années parfois sur
l'écologie logement en avatar a dit non
mais évidemment que c'est un scandale
absolu que c'est l'enfer et que ça doit
être juste vraiment horrible moi je suis
d'accord avec des films je suis d'accord
avec mathieu je suis d'accord avec
guillaume mais malgré tout si on se fait
justice soi même est ce qu'on risque pas
plus est-ce qu'on va pas les
laisser ici parce que justement on n'a
pas le droit de se faire justice soi
même que la loi est mauvaise elle allait
voir les pas une fête il faut que ça ça
évolue on commence quand l'état
aujourd'hui même si moi je pense que
j'essaierai d'intimider les personnes je
demanderai à mokhtar me donner un coup
de main bien selon
moctar sow carrière a que 6 et des
anglais
le problème c'est que est ce que moi je
tiens beaucoup plus que si on squatte
mon appartement
ma demande à maurice signolet maurice
qu'est ce qu'on risque c'est alors
l'expulsion par soi même c'est
totalement illégal depuis le mois de
mars 2014 la loi allure expulsé qu'elle
siens par soi même de son propre chef
ces trois ans de prison et 30000 euros
d'amendé
c'est ça qui est dingue c'est que
la loi la loi quand même évolué à je
vous écoute et en disant il faut changer
la loi et c'est la loi évolue en 2 en
décembre 2020 une nouvelle loi la loi
asa plaints d'accélérations et de
simplification d'action publique a été
mise en place justement pour remédier à
tout ça mais si on nous de nous laisser
emporter par l'émotion moi j'ai fait des
quand j'étais encore en activité en
commissariat il m'est arrivé de faire
des expulsions comme ça il ya deux cas
de figure via la d il ya des cas
désespérés voir désespérant et il y à
des cas où c'est vraiment la malbaie
j'ai mis un squatteur il ya le
propriétaire qui est venu pour lui dire
voilà gentiment il faut partir il a
appelé la police le squatteur
il avait raison il est dans son droit
comme erronée il a raison qu'il avait
raison mais comment qu'on n'avait pas
mais seulement à un moment il ya des
dérives oui mais la loi la loi nettement
évolué quand même reprenons quand même
la généalogie des choses pourquoi et que
cette loi était préservé énormément le
locataire rappelons-nous de l'hiver 54
avec l'abbé pierre qui a créé les
compagnons d'emmaüs à l'époque les gens
se retrouver dans une très grande
précarité il y avait une crise du
logement qui était terim les gens
travaillaient dormaient dans la rue est
donc tout à fait légitimement on à
protéger au maximum le locataire qui
pouvaient un moment donné se retrouver à
ne pas payer son loyer r c'est parce que
le mou squatteurs en termes de lois de
de droit ça n'existe pas c'est un terme
qui a été inventé par des journalistes
un haut on parle d'occupants sans titre
sans droit ni titre d'un bien d'autrui
voilà et donc on a voulu à l'époque
préserver les gens honnêtes qui se
retrouvait dans une très grande
précarité c'était pertinent
aussi du temps les choses ont évolué
c'est les gens d'une très grande
précarité etc bon il en existe encore
c'est certain mais il ya également
aujourd'hui des gens nulle très grande
malhonnêteté césar il suffit par exemple
de devenir un logement de changer la
serrure de s'inscrire au gaz d'inscrire
les enfants à l'école et c'est terminé
j'en avais pour des 1 comment ça se fait
c'est incroyable c'est comme ça mais
parce que on est dans un état de droit
on peut sais pas si on devra parler
plutôt d'un il est à des droits en
parlant de squats on va revenir sur des
ballons l'instant on va recevoir et
l'aude ils auront un jeune couple qui du
jour au lendemain ils sont passés du
rêve au cauchemar quand ils ont acheté
une maison à olemps ville dans l'essonne
à une trentaine de kilomètres de paris
en mai dernier après des années de
travail et d'heures de supplémentaires
pour pouvoir se payer maison elodie
laurent signe enfin chez le notaire
évidemment ils sont hyper heureux et
vous allez voir ce qui va se passer
petit récap ils sont avec nous juste
après
et le 10 et laurent sont les terribles
victimes de ces squatteurs et une
nouvelle affaire de maison squattée tout
est compliqué malgré les lois qui
existent alors qu'ils ont signé l'acte
de vente de leur maison en essonne
impossible pour eux de poser leurs
cartons voilà ils ont changé les plaies
donc je peux rien faire c'est fermé le
cauchemar est bien réelle une famille
avec quatre enfants soit leur nouvelle
maison depuis ce jour rien à faire pour
le coup qui vient d'engager une
procédure pour tenter de déloger cette
famille mélodies laurent le savent les
procédures peuvent être longues et il
est impossible pour eux d'agir seul ce
soir ils ont décidé de témoigner dans
tpm b pour tenter de récupérer leurs
maisons
[Musique]
merci d'être là merci bon car sinon on
va voir si elodie laurent des
propriétaires victimes de squatters on
va revenir sur toute l'histoire
l'histoire est dingue d'elodie laurent
on va reprendre l'histoire depuis le
début vous travaillé dur pour mettre
l'argent de côté vous acheter une maison
depuis combien de temps vous économisez
tous les deux ça fait deux ans deux ans
au moins voilà pourrait voir déjà un
petit pécule pour pouvoir voir un crédit
au pays un crédit oui sur sur la maison
donc on paye un crédit pour que d'autres
en profitent c'est ça vous décidez
d'acheter un bien visiter cette maison
voilà donc qu'est ce qui s'passe visiter
la maison où vous aimez bien la maison
tout va bien c'est ça on hésite la
maison en septembre dernier d'accord on
y en tirant plusieurs fois on with it on
on kiffe mais on kiffe la maison est
vide complètement vide il ya un matelas
au sol d'accord voilà je la visite
plusieurs fois tout va bien jusque là
tout va bien d'accord donc là vous
vous décidez d'acheter la maison fait
une offre l'offre est acceptée vous
faites un crédit et vous vous avez la
maison à disposition à partir de quand
oui donc c'est ça on avait eu les clés
quand vous avez les clés quand je la
signe un jour de vacances
le 19 mai d'accord donc c'était
dernièrement il ya même pas un mois là
vous avez les clés qu'est ce qui se
passe vous vous rendez dans la maison
ça donc là qu'est ce qui se passe on y
va tout de suite bien sûr bah oui normal
vous avez envie vrai vue oui j'avais des
copains qui étaient avec moi on avait
prévu de faire un barbecue pour fêter ça
on se rend là-bas y voilà on trouve on
trouve la maison comme ça la voiture les
rideaux un chien
les vélos des patinettes
donc lâché
sur tech une c'est normal bah voila je
demande un petit peu à jouve le
portillon je rentre je vais choquer je
demande de mon explication que bonjour
et que vous tombez sur qui je tombe sur
un enfant je demande à avoir un des
parrains
il est sorti et on s'est expliqués m'a
dit qu'il avait acheté cette maison
le monsieur vous a dit qu'il avait
acheté cette province et ça il a acheté
la maison donc là je comprends pas j'ai
moi aussi je les achetais voilà j'ai des
papiers je comprends pas et
et de l'ag demande de présenter des
papiers me montre ils me montrent une
promesse de vente une promesse de vente
écrit mais ça c'est pas ça fait pas
d'eux sur ces riens une promesse de
vente voilà je suis comment vous l'avez
payé je vais payer 120 mille euros en
espèces
je tombe par terre j'ai dit mais on
n'achète pas une maison sur un coin de
table c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe
il ya un acte de chez le notaire et
quelque chose et de là je vois qu'il a
il n'a pas tout ça mais mais il me dit
appelle appelle les gendarmes ils sont
au courant c'est chez moi
la donc chose que j'ai fait j'ai appelé
les gendarmes d'accord et ils m'ont
confirmé que j'étais bien le
propriétaire mais que de là il s engager
une longue procédure parce qu'il était
il était finalement chez lui la deux
chevaux
je suis
dans l'appartement alors laissons 6,6
donc elle est là ils sont trois enfants
et 84 enfants et quatre enfants et deux
adultes d'accord plus le chien donc là
qu'est ce que vous vous dites tous les
titres incendie dans une histoire
incroyable c'est incroyable à ce qui se
passe
j'ai les gendarmes ont fini par nous
dire gentiment de partir d'accords ah
oui de partir de chez vous 1,8 partir il
a fallu il a loué à évoluer monsieur
madame et ses soutes donc là vous êtes
là bas d'appeler les gendarmes ils
arrivent dit non mais si votre maison
oui mais c'est lui qui doit habiter
blanc parce que pour l'instant il toque
et 6 passes et ça faisait combien temps
qu'il était dans la maison
je pensais ça faisait quand même temps
qu'ils étaient là depuis novembre il
nous a dit novembre non moi ce que moi
la question que j'ai envie de vous poser
c'est quand vous avez visité la maison
où il avait visité combien de fois deux
fois trois fois trois fois renfort fois
avec l'agent immobilier n'était pas au
courant de ça
non non mais apparemment la maison avait
déjà été squattés d'accord auparavant la
dcl a déjà été squattés mais nous quand
la visite et un matelas par terre il n'y
avait pas de mobilier y avait pas de
freewest et des captures savait rien
s'il y avait quelqu'un qui était
installé jc peut-être des jeunes
il tente d'en temps il se pose là je
sais pas donc et vous avez essayé d'en
parler avec l'agent immobilier s'il est
au courant de ça ou pas du tout non
parce que le prix le prix était
intéressant on a voulu on a voulu nous
accélérer un petit peu limite pour
acheter on n'a pas trop voulu ébruiter
que le prix était enfin nous ça naît ça
nous connaît la peinture vous l'avez
vous l'avez trouvé comment la maison
vous avez une connaissance qui nous a
ramené à la corde accord vos années mais
voilà donc c'est vrai que la maison
était plus basse et est un prix beaucoup
plus bas que ce qui est aux alentours de
leno même soir de maison c'était
vraiment une bonne affaire c'était une
bonne affaire lamanda viendra après la
brutale bravo donc à la stib en a plein
le propriétaire à mon avis l'ancien
propriétaire est au courant que la
maison était squatté voilà où qualité
souvent ce côté ou qu'elle était déjà
squatté et s'est dit c'est tellement une
galère je vais la vendre et je vais la
mettre à un prix beaucoup plus bas pour
pouvoir voilà trouver un acheteur assez
vite et l'acheteur qui a
été cet été vous de elodie et laurent
donc là vous êtes avec la gendarmerie
pour pour partait donc chez vous vous
faites quoi j'ai fait mon barbecue ouais
chez moi comme ça pour ça et j'avais
acheté la viande mais j'aime à rouiba ça
je me suis fait un barbecue chez moi et
moi et moi vous vous perdez pas le rend
vraiment barbecue commun si ça
vous fait le barbecue d'accord à la et
quelques jours après syrte on m'a bien
sûr j'y retourne je dis non je dis aller
tout seul non non avec des copains
d'accords ouais parce que je jouerai
brel copains voix la gestuelle on va
essayer d'intimider un petit peu on va
essayer de vendre essayer de ne pas
discuter et essayer de faire quelque
chose je pouvais pas rester comme ça
bien sûr ça rend fou donc cessons a
aussi voulu jouer des lois essayer de
nous rentrer et en fait on s'est dit
qu'une fois nous on allait être rentré
peut-être qu'ils n'allaient pas pouvoir
nous sortir et s'étonner qu'on est les
vrais propriétaires essayer ça vous avez
essayé d'y aller quand on bosse de
gaieté quand il n'y avait personne à la
maison non non pas quand il était là à y
rentrer et je me suis dit je vais
escalader malgré le chien malgré malgré
qu'ils soient là et je voudrais le
portillon et puis on va se mettre dedans
wap les gendarmes on va dire bah comment
on fait du coup la guinée je suis
propriétaire il et ça va vraiment il est
chez lui aussi vous aller virer
candidats vous avez fait vous savez si
vous avez fait ça on l'a fait alors nous
on vient et nous non
c'est rigal cd garder
sa loi et la loi
le mois ci c'est le genre de truc qui me
rend fou pour vous je deviendrais fou je
vous dis arrêtez si c'est un quad donc
là pour rentrer chez vous en fait un
barbecue
et pas de barbecue mais là pour rentrer
chez eux mais bouge on nous dit vous
dites la faire et elle va jamais se
termine pour moi c'était c'était fini
c'était fini cic pas vous êtes dit quoi
alors à ce moment là bas qu'on allait en
avoir pour des années en plus vous payer
les loyers payés crédit de la maison si
vous aviez votre ancienne habitation
était en location on est toujours en
location étaient toujours en
questionnant vous êtes toujours
l'occasion donc là vous payez les deux
classes et c'est là c'est l'enfer une
fois dans la vie merlin fait qu'on a
actuellement je suis sans emploi
et vos elodie je travaille dans un
laboratoire
d'accord mais c'est donc cesser ainsi un
cauchemar donc là ensuite qu'est ce que
vous faites vous y allez avec vos potes
comme vous m'avez dit qu'est-ce qui se
passe bah ouais donc l'harmonie a été on
sert fait virer vous sonnez quand vous
soyez ou du temps non là je vais gérer
ce n'est plus un chien d'accord dès ses
années vous avez avec vos potes et là
qui m'a aboyé qui père de famille le nom
la femme en premier d'accord vous
hésitez pas là là elle a appelé lundi
connectés
un petit peu nombreux du coup ils ont
ramené aussi des copains
des copains bon ya pas eu de ya pas eu
trop de soucis ça va chauffer un petit
peu mais rien en soi rien et on a fini
par être viré aussi non n'est rentré
qu'à vous en dit quoi vous indice est
chez nous on bouge pas d'ici c'est chez
nous on bouge pas voilà ccc dont qui a
rien à faire on bougera pas d'ici on
bougera pas fais ce que tu veux monde
descend je suis chez moi et m'a dit
d'accord voilà donc de là on parle un
petit peu avec les gendarmes ont dit
mais comment on va pouvoir régler cette
histoire la commission comment que ça va
se finir parce qu'au bout d'un moment il
va falloir faire quelque chose venez
déposer une main courante
alors née une main courante on fait quoi
que la main courante bon on a déposé une
main courante on a fait constater un
huissier à je suis revenu et la
constructi la concéder quoi il est venu
où il est des plus grands traits d'un
visage un peu plus loin non il est venu
à l'extérieur d'accord il vient
extérieur il a fait quoi il constate il
vient il n'essayait pas de parler avec
les gens et voilà ils écoutent ce qu'ils
ont fait ce qu'ils avaient à leur dire
et voilà après il rédige un rapport qui
nous a transmis et kiki et nous a dit
qu'il allait engager une procédure
de la mdi veut il faut aller porter
plainte la main à la main à la main
commente ne suffit pas il faut aller
porter plainte je vers la gendarmerie
j'essaie de porter plainte ils veulent
pas prendre notre place un quoi s'ils
veulent pas prendre notre plainte parce
qu'il serait arrivé avant que ce soit
neutre notre domicile oh [ __ ] c'est
donc l'heure 19 quand je suis arrivé
j'étais déjà là donc ça signifie que
lorsque j'étais en train de signer il
était déjà là donc avant que ce soit
réellement chez moi il était déjà là
c'est donc il vous dit ils vous disent
quoi on peut pas prendre note que l'on
peut pas prendre votre plainte alors on
fait quoi a c'est ce que je leur
demandais qu'est ce qu'on va faire
qu'est-ce qu'on fait comment que ça va
se retourner contre eux qui voient dans
ce cas là faut prendre un avocat est
passée par là encore des frais d'avocat
voilà bien loin des tas des gars qui
sont saturés
ce crédit plus l'avocat
à la fin c'est toi qui te retrouves à la
rumeur qui va l'exploiter en fait non
mais ça mais c'est ça et donc là il vous
est donc là ils vous disent avoir
d'avocat vous avez fait quoi non je n'ai
pas été voir l'avocat gp je parlais avec
huissier je me suis renseigné un petit
peu et j'ai contacté les médias c'est
bien fait
bien sûr vous avez contacté les médias
vous êtes dit c'est la dernière chance
il faut que je me mets 10 énergie c'est
parce que sinon il ya dans cette affaire
c'est c'est incroyable alors juste on va
revenir et de raconter la fin de
l'histoire dans un instant vous dit que
vous l'avez acheté 140000 euros et e ce
qui choque wattignies ce qu'ils ont payé
120 millions nécessaires c'est ça en
fait est ce que cette histoire est vraie
ou est ce qu'ils ont acheté la maison
pas du tout que jamais
acheté propriétaire
la personne qu'à kilo achetés on a une
personne qui est la maison n'a jamais
appartenu donc peut-être un autre squat
heures en fait peut-être un autre côté
c'est l'histoire c'est ça c'est qu'il va
payer quelque chose aux nerfs 1000 euros
comme en
cent vingt mille euros en espèces et
gendarmes il aurait dit aux mecs c'est
qui le gars qui
sait du bleu moi je sais du studio
plutôt qu'ils se
trouvaient dans la maison dans laquelle
les oies gilbert des césars
épisode donc là là donc là il ya dix ans
il ya un truc s'il ya quelqu'un qui nous
demandent aussi sur les réseaux juste
cyril hanouna qui maintenant je ne
comprends pas l'état des lieux n'a pas
été fait avant la signature triste
vraiment j'espère qu'ils retrouveront
vite leurs maisons mais l'état des lieux
c'est vrai il a été fait ou pas
tu fais mais attendez tu fait l'état des
lieux mais entre le moment où tu visites
et le notaire il ya les trois mois il ya
toujours les deux mois exactement moi il
suffit qu'il arrive juste 48 heures
avant qu'ils aillent chez leur s est
terminée rideau tu l'as pas ta maison tu
crois tu es venu il ya deux jours tu es
passé devant avec ta voiture derrière
tsheri ici on va mettre ça et si on va
faire ça tu achètes observe ce qui s'est
passé tu viens plusieurs fois à voir la
maison là je vais faire des travaux je
vais changer la clôture mais quand tu
vas chez le notaire ils sont déjà
rentrés alors 5e avec quelques jours le
squatteur vous a proposé 5000 euros
en espèces c'est ça non c'est pas ça
c'est ils demandent ils demandent 5000
euros pour partir
la réponse à une maison qu'il a achetée
sans
nom mais dont qui vous a demandé 5000
euros pour partir tout à l'heure il m'a
demandé ma vie au roi il a été au rendez
vous avec le maire ouais il est vrai que
les religions la démo est le maire et en
revenant de chez le maire je
l'interpellent j alors qu'est-ce qui se
passe voilà vous avez partir oui c'est
bon j'ai compris je me suis fait
arnaquer j'ai des faux papiers et elle a
même fait comprendre il me
sidy bâ
dit dans un mois je m'en vais cinq ans
il ya même un délai 25 nice s'est
incliné un mois c'est même pas évident
mais c'est un mois
mais en fait c'est pas du tout fait
arnaquer ça c'est un mythe ou non oui
bien sûr ça va si le papier qu'il a
c'est à l'ordinateur n'y a pas d'entente
est assurée rien il a 3 po feuille
chiffonnée il a été voir le meilleur le
maire locaux des six il vous connaît le
maroc au rang de la sphère où il lui a
dit il le dit quoi le maire
je sais pas trop ce qui se sont égaux
devant toujours très ce que nous on a
été voir le maire également d'un combat
bien sûr mais qu'est ce qui vous a dit
une mère qui soutenait mais qu'on soit
il savait pas réellement quoi faire lui
dans cette situation qui ne pouvait pas
intervenir directement sur ça c'est la
préfecture carrément un moment où vous
avez pensé à aller sortir manier les
enfants c'est compliqué il ya des 1ers
non m enfants non mais la question est
simple d'accord moi j'ai pensé oui ou
non bah oui normal mais forcément du
monde vous avez pensé quoi vous a dit on
va les sortir je voulais sortir je vais
venir et puis au lieu de le discuter je
vais leur a joué les invités à sortir
et ça ça aurait été une mauvaise
solution
la difficulté c'est que ça n'était pas
votre domicile vous êtes propriétaire du
bien certes mais c'est pas votre
domicile aux termes de la loi un
domicile c'est un andalou on habite
réellement c'est à dire avec des meubles
avec du linge etc et ont allaité c'est
pas votre domicile alors que lui si
aussi incroyable que ça puisse paraître
les entraîne donc tous
la réponse des gendarmes je leur réponds
c'est ma pas si vous aimez vous la
réponse des gens d'un tout à fait
légitime est ce qu a eu déjà des cas il
faut moi je vous dis faut pas du tout
faire les doléances j'ai pas ce qui a eu
déjà des cas où il ya des remèdes sur
lui les ont sortis et qu'après bon moi
c'est ça c'est pas vrai ski parce
qu'elle est le squatteur pour aller
porter plainte a déclaré je suis en
retraite maintenant je peux le dire je
les fais un d'accord
cette élection pourrait y aura plus donc
a longtemps ça m'est arrivé oui parce
que quand même la mauvaise foi bien sûr
qu'on a une tête de canard des potes de
canard cependant un canard racontez nous
comment qu'est ce qui s'est passé
racontez nous ce que vous avez des cas
désespérés je voulais dit tout à l'heure
en famille minée cas désespéré et
désespérant et puis il ya des escrocs
patentés de ça il ya des gens il vous
sort des faux bond à un bail vous le
prenez dans une librairie vous allez
prendre mais c'est ça la main vous dites
que c'est un gage d paye en liquide etc
comme cette histoire cent vingt mille
euros ça tient pas la route quoi donc il
arrive un moment où
derrière le policier il ya aussi un
coeur énorme et obligations du bord des
conneries
non non non
[Musique]
les endroits un peu particulier un peu
chaud mais vous voyez que la
désespérance elle est des deux côtés il
faut savoir faut savoir peser le pour et
le contre et les choses procès serait
bien quand on a de l'autorité et qu'on
sait
on s'assied prendra sa part
totalement interdite pour exactement et
je vous lis tous ceux qui nous on ya
ceux qui ont
si il se trouve que voilà il ya des
squatters si vous ne le faites pas parce
que là ça sera encore plus un drame
avions si vous prenez trois ans de
prison orages 30000 euros d'amendé là ça
serait la lecture d'un conducteur dans
les 48 heures quand vous êtes en
flagrant délit y'a pas de problème
d'accord voilà prévenus d'un prévenu la
police ou les gendarmes les gendarmes si
effectivement ça s'est passé dans les 48
heures ils interviendront au delà des 48
heures et n'interviendront pas il ya un
nom de liste des tombes à on va où
maintenant c'est que l'afer a avancé
aujourd'hui
donc là c'était quand vous décidez de
contacter les médias quand
tu es quand
martin martine rey semaine dernière vous
avez vous contacté le parisien c'est ça
le parisien aujourd'hui en france le
parisien d'accord vous leur dites quoi
le raconter votre histoire voilà je
laisse mes coordonnées me rappelle je
raconte l'histoire émeut diba l'histoire
m'intéresse c'est ce que je peux venir
on va faire un petit article est détenu
a fait un article derrière j'ai été
contacté de nouveau par le parisien mais
pour aux services vidéo d'accord on dit
ça nous intéresse en faire un petit
reportage hélas hélas là ça a explosé
donc qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ensuite
j'ai été contacté par tous les médias
hélas là ce soir il ya eu un tweet du
ministre de l'intérieur non gérald
darmanin qui vient dire cette situation
est inacceptable
avec donc nous nous demandons
immédiatement avec le voilà
immédiatement au préfet 91 d'engager la
procédure de l'article 38 de la loi dalo
pour une évacuation rapide des occupants
illégaux donc il appartient à 38 ce
qu'est ce c'est un fait ça c'est la
dernière loi de
[Applaudissements]
réquisition du préfet le préfet a
obligation d'intervenir dans
l'immédiatement 1 il donne le préfet va
adresser une obligation partir une mise
en demeure de partir et la personne à 48
heures à la carrière si dans les 48
heures il n'a pas
il n'a pas dégagé le préfet peut
intervenir à tout moment alors il ya des
cas où le préfet va moduler un petit peu
d'attiser que là mon ami voilà par
contre là je pense que la démarche était
bon on a un prévenu
donc là ils vont recevoir quand le
demain à mon avis demain ou après demain
le prochain auxerre ce week-end ils
pourront être dans la maison j'espère
pour eux j'espère pour eux à priori
c'est toi qu'est ce qui pourrait se
passer ce qui pourrait se passer et bien
exactement l inverse de ce qu'ils ont
fait c'est à dire que la famille qu'est
la doua sur place avec quatre ou cinq
ans on n'a pas ce que j'ai compris ça
alertent les associations deux mondes
l'intervention de certains médias
faisant passer pour des malheureux et
vous allez voir la situation va se
retourner moi je trouve ce tweet la très
courageux mais méfiance il faut savoir
que iliad et des gens non c'est je veux
dire presque le métier j'ai
failli tourner tout ça donc de la
branche prudence plutôt couette parce
que c'est vous pour quatre enfants ça
peut être ils sont on va dire il ya un
délai aller à l'issue de la mise en
demeure du préfet on a deux mois pour un
tour pour demander à faire annuler la
décision du préfet auprès du tribunal
administratif de lille peuvent très bien
le demander mais est-ce que je vous dise
que j'ai peur c'est ça on est on est
dans un monde de tellement de mensonges
de manipulations et c'est qu'on peut
très bien voir demain une association
qui sienne qui viennent demain devant le
la maison s'enchaîner en disant vous
voulez vous les exploitants parce qu'à
quatre enfants et un chien je prends
plus donc
voilà je demande à voir elle demande à
voir c'est complexe vous avez bien
compris que c'est complexe parce que on
joue sur une sur sur les sentiments sur
l'émotion etc mais ça peut aller dans
les deux sens si cet après midi à une
émission de télévision où aller quatre
enfants dans la misère sans culottes et
c'est
l'opinion change du tout au tout assez
intéressant tant que je vous souhaite
c'est intéressant ce que dit mon rythme
et là c'est jugé qu il a un charme ah
oui là donc là ils ont 48 heures parce
qu'ils peuvent faire appel ou est ce qui
peut venir le fus rappelle que là c'est
suspensif donc là il faudra faire
prévenu se trouve quatre sinistres hâtif
mais le dressage durer combien de temps
pour coiffer peut aller vite dans un cas
comme ça la tribune administratif va
très vite se rendrait ses conclusions
donc si les conclusions sont bonnes sur
la région le pire il faut 48 heures ils
font appel et semaine prochaine voilà
donc lundi le préfet dit c'est bon ils
doivent partir qu'est ce qui se passe
donc les autorités peuvent venir les
sortir que l'on a fait ces jours du
matin les gendarmes ils viennent et vise
maintenant faut partir quoi d'accord
alors généralement on vient avec des
déménageurs pour emmener tous les
meubles qui a et les mettre chez
garderen dans un vote 505 mais je vous
dis je vous alerte
on peut très bien avoir un retour de
manuel fouette x 2 x 2 prudents alors
encore twitter hier 20 minutes il ya dix
huit suite à notre instruction un arrêté
de mise en demeure a été pris ce jeudi
donc c'est la largeur dit donc voilà par
le préfet 80 ans afin d'expulser la
famille des squatters cette situation
inacceptable va prendre fin et les
véritables propriétaires vont pouvoir
retrouver leurs maisons
donc ça c'était donc là c'est donc 48
heures donc si tout se passe bien
normalement voilà ça ça me démange lundi
vous êtes dans la maison assurément
après vous dites vous ça les gens
comment dire et ça qu'est ce qu'il fait
là le ministre de l'intérieur il fait
quoi dans un cas comme ça vous savez
c'est c'est très bien d'avoir fait ce
que vous avez fait c'était la meilleure
est la meilleure solution souvenons nous
de ces retraités qui avait récupéré leur
logement c'est exactement ils ont fait
la même démarche mais je vous dis
méfions-nous en fait je voudrais pas
nous leur avons pas donné de vous dire
avec ce matériau j'ai déjà vu des cas
j'ai vu des corps vraiment été flagrant
là moi moi là dessus c'est tellement
médiatisé je pense que nos communes
fleuries qui est tellement pur pour
laurent elodie que je déconseille à ceux
qui voient là qui veulent voilà encore
ce mec à travers des associations non
c'est le quotidien ouais ouais mais bon
oui mais là là là c'est franchement
c'est indéfendable qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous de vous y croyez maintenant
laurent et audi vous move n'y croyez
vous dites encore ça va être encore une
otan vous n'êtes pas dedans on n'y
croyait pas tant que je suis pas dedans
j'y crois pas moi vraiment là pour
l'instant je suis très content de ce
qu'a fait monsieur le ministre oui mais
mais tant que je suis pas dedans pour
moi ce sera fini quand vous dites too
many ailleurs on vient de le dire il ya
des recours il ya des voilà dix ans que
je suis là dedans ça donne l espoir bien
sûr bien sûr la sphère halal halal après
avoir évolué à l'avancé
incroyablement époque là vous allez
attendre quoique à 48 heures sur le
papier ses marques et même 24 heures ils
sont invités à quitter les lieux dans 24
heures il ya l'heure c'est 17h05
aujourd'hui donc demain 17h05 ils sont
censées avoir quitté les lieux vous
allez me tenir au courant même de 20 sur
donc l'adoma 17h05 vous êtes en train de
faire 17h06 et un barbecue
on a rien à 48 heures pour expulser mais
pas dans les premières 24 heures adacore
dire qu'on laisse ses premières 24
heures à la personne pour pour partir
d'accords donc c'est sa voie
professionnelle m et sinon ces 48 heures
indique voilà donc mais oui j comme il
ya quatre enfants scolarisés il va
falloir que la poursuite des études
scolaires soit assurée et comme il ya
quatre enfants il va falloir au moment
de l'expulsion ou juste après qu'ils
aient un logement de la famille assurée
par les autorités donc le délai il est
parfait j'espère pour vous c'est pas
tout à fait aussi simple que ça ça peut
prendre un peu plus de temps
grâce aux tweets de darmanin et grâce à
la médiatisation j'espère vraiment pour
vous que ce week-end vous serez dans
votre maison non je la larve cube et
pourquoi pas si vous avez des
végétariens je viens je voulais juste en
fait à toutes les personnes qui sont
dans ce cas là et qui n'ont pas eu
l'opportunité de médiatiser en fait donc
il faudrait que monsieur le ministre en
regardant ça ne se mêler panique mais
pourquoi en tous les cas moi j'y très
vite un papa tous les cas qui lui
remonte la logique la super
bowl en parlant de ce cas là il faut
qu'il faut traiter c'est la base du cas
surtout la loi qui célèbrent les bons
c'est la loi mais l'epa ministre de la
justice
normale et mike partout non plus mais
après quand même non mais c'est vrai
voilà il est ministre de l'intérieur
pour l'instant voilà il s'est beaucoup
du duc de l'agglo à tige quand même à
tout ça naturel ça c'est beaucoup de la
compétence du préfet donc de
l'administratif donc là on rappelle
demain 24 heures normalement il doit
repartir à
17h05 mais ils peuvent rester en fait
ils peuvent être utilisés que 48 heures
après donc ce serait voilà ce serait
donc samedi à 17h05 si le papa samedi là
doit être exposée mais comme a dit voilà
il faudrait pas que voilà l opinion
publique toronto se retourne et que ça
fasse un trouble à l'ordre public et
danser car elle le préfet pourrait
surseoir il est obligé de deux
d'entériner la décision du ministre sauf
s'il ya trouble à l'ordre public et le
fait que des enfants soient dans ma
nature peut être un trouble à l'ordre
public clément moi je suis demandé 5000
euros déjà
bien sûr ça y est
il a su que le ministre bien sûr parce
qu'il a sur ces sujets il vous a dit moi
on va vous donner 5 millions il a durant
la le maire a dû lui dire tu as sont là
ça y est elle née milliard de gens mais
c'est perdu ses paniers vous allez
sortir
il ya une loi qui fait qu' ils peuvent
vous sortir donc il s'est dit je lui
proposais 5000 euros au moins que je
prenne 5 milliard en deux parties un
bref arrêt mais le truc c'est que là je
ne vois pas comment l'opinion publique
pourrait se retourner après la
proposition de 5000 euros quand malone
est donc là avance à dix enfants
j'espère que ça devrait aller vraiment
cessé en plus j'ai l'impression vous
discuté beaucoup avec lui bages et
celles dont vous êtes resté vachement
pour toi j'ai l'impression à huy a
vraiment vraiment moi on m'a vivement
conseillé de rester coi est gentil ouais
c'est donc c'est ce que j'ai fait et
éloignez vous vous en vous en pour vous
n'en pouvez plus vous voulez vous avant
de dire à laurent il faut il faut les
sortir on n'en peut plus la whey où j'ai
pu essayer de le raisonner par ici de
lui-même il les aurait peut-être sorti
en mai
mais oui forcément enfin ça fait une
depuis le 19 mai on pense qu'à ça on
ressasse on imagine les plombs les plus
improbables pour essayer de récupérer
les lieux après tout nous dit aussi de
pâques ça peut se retourner contre nous
donc on fait tout pour mais ouais c'est
elle et dans quel état la maison là à
lhassa bon là ça pour l'instant ça va à
peu près bon s'est il ya des rats et des
rats qui sont arrivés c'est ça le bar
garder voilà un bon il vaut coupe était
un partant on a vu des réduits vous avez
vu d'hier à aujourd'hui sa première fois
est donc là un manager et en plus il va
avoir encore un travail et puis à la
base la maison est pas un enfin il pas
aux normes surtout que ce soit y la
plomberie l'électricité il ya encore de
l'amiante au niveau du sous-sol enfin
vous avez des enfants à la base bien
d'accord donc là vous allez mettre la
maison decker si vous pouvez la
retrouver et évacuer les rares donc la
même si vous y allez allez bon c est du
boulot quoi allah ya du boulot ballet du
boulot ouais bon si je reprend
possession et le secteur it comment vous
allez faire parce que vous êtes encore
en location donc là vous allez aller
direct à la maison si demain voilà 17h05
qui sont partis là vous êtes dans la
maison du boulanger vont immédiatement
je bouge plus m6 a déraillé à des rares
on va dormir
souhaite en tout cas vous nous tenez au
commando mais on vous dit comment ça
s'est passé est vraiment faut que
j'espère que voilà il faut j'espère
qu'il aura pas de mauvaises surprises et
que ça va pouvoir le faire il o'neal
remettra au barbecue avec peut dire
venez écouter avec plaisir j'adore la
merguez voilà
merci elodie laurent et franchement vous
gardez vous êtes formidable et on a
tellement envie que ça se passe bien
pour vraiment géant francs minuit on va
vraiment suivre cette affaire et on en
reparlera s'il faut encore si ça se fait
pas pour vraiment que ça ça rebouge
encore